she's an activist an actress who stars
at NBC's superstar starting its second
season on September 22nd America Ferrara
what a great pleasure to meet you
are you doing
there okay America knew you are a
surrogate for Hillary Clinton
what is surrogate I know what a
supporter is but I'm not sure what a
surrogate is well um I'm a supporter and
I just travel the country into different
cities and and just talk about why I
support Hillary and you were with her
from the beginning I mean you're not
like oh I was for this guy and this guy
and now it's Hillary I'm you this your
girl yeah I was out campaigning in 2008
as well so you watch the Republican
convention
I should have been hard well I listened
and I could only take it in like small I
in the same way it was hard to take but
would you care to offer a rebuttal to
the people at the convention who who
said that she should be locked up how
much time do we have plenty you know
when I came away with was first and
foremost a stomach ache um because it
makes me physically ill you know it does
it makes me sick to think about the lies
they were plotting you getting so lies
yeah thank you uh lies lies lies lies
lies and um a lot of lies and and from
and and one issue that I care deeply
about because I happen to be Latino
American is immigration and he could not
have been more wrong he's just wrong
he's wrong specifically about the fact
that immigrants are criminals
right we're in fact because there are
such things as facts yes um
in fact criminals are lieu of criminals
sorry wait he's got you now is he's got
me um immigrants are less immigrants
undocumented or documented are less
likely to commit crime now who drives
perfectly Latinos cuz they don't want to
[ __ ] with the police everybody else in
LA drives like a maniac I met a woman in
here behind a truck with a lawnmower
never ever does
it's true that's stereotyping though
maybe maybe so but it's true
maybe I met a woman in Arizona who
doesn't play her music because if she
plays it too loud and she's an American
documented she's like if they pulled me
over I will go crazy and they will shoot
me I don't play my music we're saying
the same thing what I just said yes
exact area typer
yeah but he was wrong about criminals
and he was wrong about about the economy
I mean okay so here's the thing
Donald Trump is is getting zero percent
of the black vote which is really hard
to do to get zero to get a hundred
percent of people malaria happens when
you don't disavow the Klu Klux Klan
right okay but he's getting I think in
Pennsylvania Ohio he's getting zero
percentage he's nearing that nationally
but not so with the Hispanic vote I
would think they would hate him even
more who are these Hispanic people who
are for trouble well here's the thing I
think is that Latino Americans are
Americans which people don't want to
believe but we are Americans your name
is my name and I have a pin yeah in case
we forgot your names you forgot Latino
Americans are Americans and they care
about the same things that all Americans
care about so of course there's going to
be a portion of the Latino American
population that is angry and sees and
Donald Trump a channel for that anger
and and and but but by no means is there
even close to equanimity or a majority
of Latinos who are out there for Trump
don't we see much in the nation at least
one it just odd to me that there's any
and the good news the good it's on to me
too oh it's mind-boggling right but the
good news is that in California we've
seen record registration among Latinos
and this in state and in the Sikh
I see that the the Democrats not for the
Republican yeah I see that the never
Bernie people are showing up in
Philadelphia next week and I'm wondering
what your message is you mean NEVER
Hillary never Bernie I'm sorry just I
never Bernie I mean Bernie or bust
Bernie ever Bernie or bust people are
showing yeah Bernie or buzz people right
thing you are showing up at philippi
what what is your message to the Bernie
folks who can't seem to get on board you
know there's only two choices on the
menu that's what I say to them do you
really want to eat poisoned vomit yeah I
think that I think that it's reckless
and I think that there's a political
reality and one of these two people is
gonna be the next president of the
United States most likely and to sit
around and not make a choice is it to
make a choice you are making a choice by
sitting around and not getting on board
and not only registering I mean I'm sure
Bernie supporters are registered to vote
but it's not enough anymore for us to be
registered and show up ourselves we need
to register our friends our families our
communities and and you know it's
hilarious that every election every
presidential election two months before
the election everybody's like how do we
turn out the minority vote you're too
little too late like every year is an
election year and and you can't just
show up to communities that are
under-resourced and undereducated about
civics and that there's there is an
active campaign against voter rights and
it's high right it's hard to vote in
America it's down to vote I mean we
don't have it like a lot of countries do
on the weekends right yeah hey you know
who's making it harder of course we do
public right I mean that's how they win
elections they do
have to give ya more credit than you
apparently give your own people
you can vote looking about 30 days in
advance in most states and a simple we
can finances it's more than one rule if
you're on the ballot I'm on the ballot I
can promise you I'll tell you this but I
will be glad to talk to any of your
friends are you afraid and explain to
them how easy it is you guys feel just
doing this right because it stirs up in
Maricopa County in Arizona they reduced
after the Supreme Court ruling of
gutting the the the Voting Rights Act
Wow a dead people off the rolls
no no they reduce the number of polling
places right 400 to 60 yeah that's why
they were lines that's why people oh hi
oh they reduce early voting and Ohio
they maybe they don't want bit vote I
don't know why you guys can't give your
people more credit they can get to the
pulse this is a rhetorical can't say
something and I want to throw the
retirement we're talking about was talk
about why is voter fraud there's one
right acts in 17 states that preserve
and protect the rights of the minorities
absolute not just in 17 states but in
other counties in cities like Chicago
unfortunately New York want to speak to
this because I think that's a teaser
this is the lie in the lack of nuance
that confuses people because it promotes
the lie that Latinos and people of color
don't show up because they're lazy and
they don't care that is a lie another
one favor
job right they have to take a day off to
travel 20 miles to get to the nearest
government office didn't I do there so
to valid is you I've been on the ballot
before I represented a rule area did you
with that because this is not pretend
you're little bit they're everywhere in
the country there's absentee ballot uh
there is it is very similar in America
it's not pretend you eligible apathy in
this country is high that's and the
reason the other Brits ended up leaving
Europe the biggest own-goal ever shot in
the history a developed country is
because people under 24 didn't show up
like 34 percent of them bothered they
didn't right here specially Erica and
once here I'll come in this country
yeah if people don't and I'm a damn and
I and that is easily an outcome we can
see and nobody everybody's fired up I
promise I know that watching so George
I'll show you how you know this is
really important yeah yellow floral
election right
we either gonna like the first female
president or the last president period
people may be a part of this less he
believed me for this drama I did a nice
female dancers and he does something